[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous merci d'être
venus si nombreux mieux coûté à pour
parler d'économie
l'économie c'est prouvé et je vais vous
prouver ce soir qu'il est plus
économique de travailler de façon plus
écologique que de ne pas faire chapelle
mehdi duteil et je vais travailler dans
une entreprise qui est industrielle dans
laquelle l'argent le résultat de
l'entreprise n'est pas un une fin en soi
mais plutôt un moyen d'entreprendre
en clair c'est à dire que étant donné
qu'on est une entreprise qui est
indépendante nous distribuons pas de
dividende
et donc nous réinvestissons
systématiquement le résultat dans
l'entreprise est toujours sous trois
critères le premier c'est qu'il faut
toujours baisser l'impact de l'activité
sur l'environnement baisser la
pénibilité ou dangerosité des postes et
troisième critère gagner de la
productivité c'est un cercle vertueux
quoi mais ce cercle vertueux pourrait
dissimuler des conditions de travail qui
sont peu souhaitable étant donné que
nous attendons de nos collègues qu'ils
donnent le meilleur d'eux mêmes nous
leur proposons donc le meilleur contrat
de travail c'est un cdi pour tous
l'écart entre le plus bas et le plus
haut salaire va de 1 à 4 c'est une
cohérence salariale qui est décomplexé
en contrepartie de quoi nous avons mis
en place un plan de déplacement employés
qui dans son extrême va jusqu'à du
covoiturage par quatre dans des voitures
électriques
grâce à ça chacun de nos salariés
bénéficient de réductions de ses
dépenses pour venir travailler et
rentrer chez eux
200 à 300 euros par mois nous avons
aussi autour du site industriel des
espaces verts qui sont cultivés en
permaculture est aussi un verger
conservatoire et de maraude ce qui nous
permet de proposer chaque semaine un
panier de fruits et légumes pour le coup
locaux et puis aussi sans pesticides et
de saison nous avons aussi un professeur
de running qui vient donner des cours de
course à pied pour nous aider à
atteindre des objectifs de course à pied
semi marathon marathon pour les plus
ambitieux et puis aussi un professeur de
renforcement musculaire cuisses abdos
fessiers et un professeur
2 un ostéopathe pardon un ostéopathe qui
vient pour soigner les conséquences d'un
travail en machine qui peut être
difficile physique et aussi répétitif
pour terminer sur ce sujet je vous
dirais qu'on a une
troc et notre hiérarchie qui est
classiquement pyramidale où on a souvent
un comité de direction une équipe et
entre deux des cadres intermédiaires
chez nous on a un comité de direction ou
de pilotage composé de trois hommes et
trois femmes pour la parité des sexes et
puis le reste de l'équipe
ça nous a permis ainsi de
responsabiliser toute l'équipe de monter
en compétences et l'équipe se porte
beaucoup mieux alors vous pourriez
croire que je vous parle d'une start up
est bien mais pas tort nous fabriquons
dans le nord un produit de haute
technologie à faire pâlir toute la
silicon valley californienne puisque
j'ai l'honneur de vous présenter un
produit qui tient dans la paume de la
main une enveloppe nous en fabriquant 2
milliards chaque année qui permettent de
vous envoyer via nos clients toutes les
bonnes nouvelles que vous aimez recevoir
chaque jour dans vos boîtes aux lettres
les relevés de compte les factures les
revues de prestations les amendes et les
impôts de rien de rien c'est notre
métier et
et donc ça c'est fabriqué dans le nord
par une équipe de 130 personnes
et puis on a découvert que l'économie
s'était vraiment pour nous un levier
économique qui nous permettait de gagner
de la productivité et de répondre à
derrida des critères pardon qui pouvait
correspondre à ce que nos clients
pouvaient pouvait attendre alors parler
d'écologie alors qu'on utilise plus de
dix mille tonnes de papier par an vous
pourriez penser que je parle là de
quelque chose qui s'apparente à du
greenwashing
eh bien pas du tout les papiers que nous
utilisons sont tracés certifié fsc pfc
puisqu'on est en europe ont fait pas ce
que l'on veut il est papier proviennent
de finlande d'allemagne et aussi de
france il faut savoir que le papier en
aucun cas n'est responsable de la
déforestation ce que j'ai pu souvent
entendre avant d'intégrer dans
l'entreprise on coupe avant tout des
arbres pour en faire du bois de
construction bois d'ameublement bois de
chauffage et sec les déchets forestiers
que l'on fait du papier c'est à dire les
copeaux de syrie et les branchages et à
chacun bras coupé trois sont replantés
dans le respect de la biodiversité des
espèces et aussi par coupes d'éclaircie
parler encore d'écologie alors qu'on
utilise des encres pour imprimer les
logos nos clients sur les enveloppes
encore une fois greenwashing eh bien non
on a travaillé on a cherché on a trouvé
une recette d'encre qui est aujourd'hui
à base d'eau de pigments naturels sans
composés organiques volatils et aussi
sans métaux lourds alors par la même
occasion nos collègues ont pu se
débarrasser des masques et des gants
qu'il devait porter quand il manipule et
ses encres parler d'écologie là qu'on
utilise d'école pour fabriquer nos
enveloppes greenwashing
tout sent pas nos hauts cols sont
aujourd'hui à gré alimentaire sans
composés organiques volatils et sans
squelette de poissons ni d'animaux alors
on sait on a trouvé toutes ces recettes
là et on s'est aperçu qu'elle était
évidemment plus écologique mais aussi
plus économique et donc on a vraiment
appliquée l'économie à nos produits
finis ce qu'on pourrait appeler ça de
l'éco-conception et après on a fait ce
travail sur nos produits on a appliqué
ce concept l'économie entreprendre sans
détruire à notre bâtiment lusine elle
date de 1848 et comme on est dans le
nord c'est on peut facilement imaginer
une usine comme les décrit si bien
isola c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
toiture qui était très perméable c'était
un gouffre énergétique
il faisait très chaud l'été très froid
l'hiver et quand il pleuvait ce arrive
de temps en temps chez nous il fallait
positionner des sceaux au sol pour
récupérer l'eau de pluie qui tombait et
qui passe à travers la toiture et donc
quand il a fallu la rénover cette au
tueur il y avait deux solutions qui se
présentaient à nous la première solution
classique à 800000 euros
c'est une toiture en tôle ondulée qui ne
faisait qu'un amortissement deuxième
solution une toiture c'est qu'on a
aujourd'hui qui qui dispose de plusieurs
technologies qui a coûté 2 millions 100
mille euros presque le triple de
l'investissement de la première solution
mais cette deuxième toiture elle fait
même un retour sur investissement
je m'explique on à 1700 mètres carrés de
panneaux photovoltaïques qui nous permet
de produire l'équivalent de 200 1000
kilowatts heure chaque année réinjectée
dans le réseau edf et donc de vendre
l'équivalent de 120 mille euros et c'est
ainsi que la toiture en partie fait un
retour sur investissement on a trois
mille mètres carrés aussi de toitures
végétalisées nous c'est des végétaux ou
plantes grasses qui ont été sélectionnés
avec le laboratoire botanique de
bailleul
donc c'est des plantes qui coûte qui
correspondent exactement au climat du
nord pas de calais et figurez vous que
quand il pleut ça arrive de temps en
temps chez nous que deux fois une fois
trois mois et une fois six mois là les
végétaux consomme 50 % de l'eau de pluie
et les restants les autres 50% vont dans
des cuves de récupération d'eau de pluie
cette eau de pluie on utilise pour
entretenir la permaculture chez nous on
l'utilisent aussi pour les chasses d'eau
dans les toilettes et aussi pour
nettoyer les stations d'impression les
stations d'impression c'est une étape de
nos machines qui va imprimer les logos
de nos clients sur les enveloppes
il faut nettoyer ses stations
d'impression régulièrement non plus avec
l'eau du réseau mais de l'eau de pluie
l'eau qui en ressort évidemment aller
soulier en encre mais pas toxique
étant donné la recette que j'ai plus
d'encre que j'ai pu expliqué auparavant
7 auparavant la stocker dans des cuves
de 16 mètres cubes et tous les mois il
ya un camion citerne qui venait pomper
cette eau pour l'envoyer dans une
cimenterie pour recyclage ça coûte et
30000 euros par an aujourd'hui on a
cassé lance un parking et on ya planté
une prairie de bambou c'est une
bambouseraie de phytoremédiation
c'est un traitement naturel par les
plantes on va y injecter de l'eau
souillée en encre etc le système
racinaire et ces bactéries qui va venir
consommer les molécules et puis
permettre aux bandes ou de pousser en
surface alors quand le bambou a atteint
sa taille adulte qui est de 5 à 6 mètres
après quatre ou cinq ans il faut que
l'on coupe l'asim sur un mètre pour
réactiver l'ensemble du système et la
chute d'un mètre on va là c'est celle à
réduire en pellets et alimenter notre
chaudière à bois
si vous n'avez bien suivi grâce à 2 2
puis on arrive à se chauffer et c'est de
répéter ça vos amis dans leur parce que
si vous leur dit simplement le résumé
vous vont prendre pour des fous
voilà c'est ce que je pouvais vous dire
ce soir sur l'économie appliquée chez
pocheco je vous ai parlé d' enveloppe je
vous ai parlé d'une usine mais ce que je
voulais vous dire aussi c'est que si on
a réussi avec 130 collègues dans une
usine dans le nord qui fait des
enveloppes qui est un produit moribond
c'est que chacun peut assassiner shell y
contribuer toute entreprise grands
groupes citoyens
voilà merci à vous
[Applaudissements]